[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes it's the 4th of august and i'm
cindy you the broadcast editor at the
spectator
the tory leadership contest is now list
trusses to lose is the writing on the
wall i'll be speaking to katie balls and
the historian robert toomes i'll also be
joined by the pollster john curtis to
chat about the power of polling
next beijing is having a tantrum over
nancy pelosi's visit to taiwan i'll be
speaking to taiwanese journalist brian
ho in mandarin about the view from
taipei
i'll also be joined by the historian
rana mitter who writes this week's cover
article on china's impending baby bust
its young are simply not having enough
babies
what does this mean for the future of
chinese power
and from china to russia our sanctions
working i'll be joined by dr richard
connolly to discuss
and finally instead of think tanks why
don't we have theft tanks the
spectator's wikiman columnist rory
sutherland will be on the show
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today your page has
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe go to spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash tv offer and why not
subscribe to our youtube channel click
the red subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon to
make sure you never miss an episode
another week another set of polls
showing list trust way ahead of rishi
sunak though this week saw her first
blunder over the pay of public sector
workers across the country will anything
turn the list trust tide
i'm joined by deputy political editor
katie balls and the historian robert
toomes
katie and robert welcome to spectator tv
now katie can you update viewers on
what's happened in the torrey leadership
campaign over the last week because it
does look like less trust is the one
with the momentum with a number of
cabinet endorsements over the last seven
days
yes it was still technically in the
early stages of the tory leadership
campaign
uh the the victor the new premise is not
announced to early september but this
week the ballots are going out slightly
delayed uh due to security concerns and
there is an expectation amongst some mps
but not all that members will vote
fairly quickly
and when you're looking at the polling
liz trust him is pretty far out in front
the ugov poll conservative home pole all
pointing to a really big lead but rishi
soon as supporters and his campaign team
are saying that when they look at the
polls it doesn't actually correlate to
what they're hearing on the ground they
think it's much closer than this now of
course they would say that because it's
uh in their interest to make it seem as
though this race is not a done deal but
i think it is just worth bearing in mind
how tricky it is to poll the membership
and that's why we have to you know
with all these different factors at play
i think the the by far the bookie's
favorite right now is liz trust it feels
though the most likely situation by some
margin is that she's the next prime
minister but it is not over till it's
over robert how do you feel about liz
trust's head start here because you had
written for the spectator before that
you were endorsing kemi badenoch but
obviously she's no longer in the race
yes quite so um yes i i i do hope that
liz trusts will be uh chosen i'm not a
party member so i have no say in the
matter but i think partly because of
what she said partly because of what
she's done
um and not a little because of who
supports her and who doesn't
uh and the people i tend to trust
support her and the people whom i'm not
quite so willing to trust tend to be
against her
that's the best i can do i'm afraid as
an outside observer that's what i that's
what makes me for my view
are you not a little bit cynical about
the cabinet endorsements that have gone
to her in the last few days and the
non-cabinet ones people like former
rivals tom tuckenhair penny mordant
sajid javid
you know when you say people who support
her does seem like a lot of ambitious
politicians who support her
uh yes
i'm quite cynical uh as everyone else is
uh but of course not everyone is
supporting them because they think they
get a job uh and uh some of the people
i'm thinking of are people who have not
liked to get cabinet posts won't mention
any names and also of course people
outside outside the house of commons
who who support her too
and
i mean the thing that can the things
that count for me are to some extent
the the northern ireland protocol you
know i think this has become
partly a symbol and also something of
real importance
and uh it seems clear that rishi sunak
is drawing back from trying to resolve
this question and this trust seems to be
willing to
take the bull by the horns
and i think that the protocol has become
really a sort of acid test for attitudes
to
to to brexit not not whether you're for
it or against it but what you think it
really means in practice and whether you
think you should push ahead or try to
limit the the effects and i think liz
trust clearly thinks that you have to go
for being more than just another norway
and katie speaking of pushing ahead with
liz trust i mean that does seem like it
embodies her entire campaign her entire
personality you write in the spectator
this week about her foreign policy which
is very much pushing ahead tell us about
that
yeah well i mean a part of that is the
northern ireland protocol as we just
heard and the fact she does take a more
bullish approach i think rishi sunak is
far more concerned about
the risk of sparking a trade war the eu
during a cost of living crisis whereas
liz trust as she said in the hustings
this week feels the only thing that you
really recognize is strength and force
and therefore you have to be bold in
your approach and i also think it's
worth noting uh when liz trust gave her
first uh party conference speech as
foreign secretary she didn't mention the
eu once uh which i think gives you a
sense i would say of her priorities um
when we're talking about her foreign
policy because what she has pioneered
during her time in the foreign office um
hadn't been appointed last september is
effectively this idea of network of
liberty that's what she refers to as her
supporters do and i think when it comes
to how she views the world it's pretty
black and white in the sense of
do you support liberty and freedom or
are you against it and i think that
dictates how she wants to work with
countries whether that is on security
alliances or even trade
well i was very encouraged by katie's
article uh because i think the the world
has changed very much since 2016. then
we were thinking that our our foreign
policy was dominated by our relations
with the eu but i think what's happened
in the last year or more less than a
year is that we've come to realize that
the eu is is not really a source of
strength is not a source of security and
is not really a viable partner and an
ambitious global policy which at first
looked like just words seems to me now
and i think i thought this is what i
drew from katie's article is really
something that we have to do
our security and our trading interests
push us in that direction and i think
that liz trusts if if she can do it uh
at least has has that vision
robert very finally and briefly is there
anything that russia senate can do to
persuade you to go uh to support him at
least uh in principle uh even if you
don't have a vote or do you think uh he
has greatest opportunity are with the
undecided tory voters
well he he's i think he's the candidate
of the undecided and in in a way he's
the candidate of the non-tories um and
and not i don't mean this as a criticism
of him i think he's from all i know of
him he's a man of intelligence honesty
charm all the rest and and i think has a
lot to offer but i think he is the
orthodox candidate and he above all has
become the candidate of treasury
orthodoxy and i think that this is not
what we want
at the moment and i think some of the
language he uses is is rather talking
down to the electorate you know talking
about the the nation's credit card and
that sort of thing that's not that's not
how the economy works
and i think that his insistence on
an orthodox retrenchment policy as we're
heading into a probable recession is
simply the wrong and the most dangerous
thing that one could do but i think it's
typical of the treasury's attitude over
the years robert toomes and katie balls
thank you so much for joining spectator
tv
so let's take a look at those polls then
a recent ugov one had the foreign
secretary 40 points in front of rishi
sunak while another said the difference
was just five percentage points are the
pulses missing something and are there
any signs of risky scenario catching up
i'm joined now by sir john curtis
professor of politics at the university
of strathclyde
professor john curtis thank you so much
for joining spectator tv now let's start
with a straightforward one why is there
such a discrepancy between the different
polls
well we'd like to notice the answer that
questions
um
the two organizations did their polling
somewhat differently yougov of course
have this quite substantial panel of
people who
are willing to answer their polls
almost in every one of the difficulties
with running such a panel is that you're
more likely to get people who are
interested in politics to participate in
them and those who are not one of the
things that
yougov amongst others have been trying
quite hard to correct in recent years um
because that can be a disadvantage when
it comes to general election if you've
got
people who are more likely to turn out
to vote then you may underestimate some
of the differences in turnout and that
was certainly part of the story
behind the problems that the polls had
back in
2015 but the upside of course is that it
does mean that you are much more likely
to have members of political parties in
your panel because they are by
definition just important so that's the
way you go doing things that's also the
way that opinion uh
attend two things as well
technique who are the company that came
up with something different though first
of all they're relatively new to poland
in the uk although they're well
established in italy which is their
place
what they did to get their numbers from
what one can tell is i mean it was
basically part of a much bigger polling
operation in which they were sending out
emails at random to a database of people
whose email addresses they have and also
uh tell it bringing telephone numbers
outline them to a database of telephone
numbers they hard so this is less in the
way of pre-selected people um part of
you know just part of the general public
in the course of that picked up
800 people who said they were
conservative members so it's a different
methodology
the two companies have produced not this
similar results of their estimates and
voting tensions of the public in general
over recent months but they clearly
diverged in this case i think all one
can say is that you know techni is a new
company and maybe they're right or maybe
they're wrong
ugov's record of um leadership polls is
a pretty good one they were virtually
spot on in their estimates of the
proportion of labour party members that
we're going to vote for jeremy corbyn in
2015 and 2016. they were pretty much
spot on in the battle between cameron
and david davis in 2005 though they were
a little bit high
on boris johnson's score in the 2019
contest equally opinion who are the
other company who've done this in the
past and they're promising us
i know the poll next week they've got a
pretty good record indeed they've got
the boris johnson versus jeremy hunt
contest almost down to a single point so
it's a difficult thing to do we are
trying to get hold of a very specialist
section of the population they represent
less than one percent of the population
but one has to say given their record in
the past one certainly cannot ignore
what comes out from the companies
that
um have been doing this on a regular
basis and i guess the worrying thing for
the sun up camp is that
it's not just that the you know new
government showing this trust well ahead
um as indeed our conservative home with
their
survey of their of their members um but
also that apparently the story has been
the the movement has been our way from
which you've sent out towards uh towards
this trust and the truth is actually if
you looked at the technical you looked
at some of the innards and again you
could see some of rishi sunat's problems
so
there were hardly any issues in which
technique
had
uh british sunnah why they had they
wanted to about civil rights lgbt rights
a little bit on on the economy but uh
whereas there were a number of issues
like immigration and others where this
trust was well ahead and actually
one could say well first of all let's
number even that ball had this class
ahead but secondly actually the overall
numbers of 48 to 43 for trust
seemed rather surprisingly narrow given
some of the other figures that were that
were there
and john we know we think of polls as
these things that measure voting intent
but with the polls coming out during the
race uh it surely has an influence on
how the race is panning out as well for
example the polls that we've just been
talking about they lend this out of
inevitability towards list trust's
victory and presumably that influences
whether it's other mps or other voters
into backing the win and course
well i'm talking about voters in general
um i mean the research that's been done
on this will tell you that for every
indication that you can pick up a
so-called bandwagon effect of people
hiding in behind the party that's ahead
you can find another one where there's
an underdog event where people seem to
pile in the opposite direction right
we're not talking about
a polling of the general public we're
talking about
a small audience and where the outcome
is going to affect people's careers
inside the conservative party and i
suppose what is notable
is that even though liz trusts in the
end only just scraped onto the ballot um
if she does win this contest i think you
know she's going to be as low as anybody
who's been in terms of the
share of the uh supportive mps at the
final stage of the mps process
but despite that all of the
announcements we have got since the
senior mps including those
who either took part would hope to take
part in the leadership but have all been
coming out in favor of this trust now
not for me to impugn the motives of
those who've done this doubtless they
are telling us what they in their
judgment is indeed the best thing for
their party for the country but
shall we say if you were wanting to
keep your open your chances of being in
this trusted new covenant then such
statements perhaps may not be regarded
as unhelpful towards your uh your career
progression and to that extent at least
clearly um it can make a difference
to uh the way in which mps work but i
think it's also true that you know some
of rishi sunak's tactics have been
affected by the polling the
way which he tried quite clearly to try
to see if he could steamroller put this
trust on the back foot in the bbc debate
something which in the end for some
people came across as mother to
aggressive and mansplaining i know that
almost undoubtedly was saying i've got
what i've got to try to do here is to
persuade people that i am actually more
effective prime minister more confident
which indeed
is one of the attributes one of the most
few attributes on which even in the
current polling which is
does score uh relatively well so again
tactics of the candidates can be mapped
it does of course
perhaps raise the question given that
this trust is apparently so far ahead as
to why she has carried on making so many
policy announcements
with therefore the risk that you make
one that leads you into trouble which
clearly happened to her
this week with the announcement about
regional papers once you're ahead just
stick to your message the narrative is
working the narrative that i am the
empathetic ordinary girl who grew up in
paisley and leeds i went to
comprehensive school and i'm opposing
this posh boy from winchester it's a
narrative which we can question
but it's a johnson style narrative in
terms of its effectiveness with the tory
membership together with of course
addressing the angst inside the
conservative party about the fact that
it's found itself presiding over high
levels of spending and high levels of
taxation is projected to do so uh into
the near future um it's just that he's
addressing that angst she has found a
picture way of selling herself uh to
certainly the right of her party um and
uh you know therefore in the end
therefore um
why does she need to make more policy
announcements she doesn't need any more
policy announcements she just needs to
keep on sticking to her current tune
because that current tune has won so far
that rishi sunak has not been able to
significantly uh cancel fascinating
professor john curtis thank you so much
away from the tory leadership contest
something huge is happening across the
world beijing is in the middle of a
tampa tantrum carried out with missile
launches and jets flying over the taiwan
strait all of this triggered by congress
speaker nancy pelosi's visit to the
island a trip that the white house
advised against
so what is the situation like in taiwan
now i'm joined by brian ho editor of new
bloom magazine in taipei
spectator tv
um
foreign
foreign
the
um
um
taiwan
china may for now be throwing its weight
around taiwan but will it be able to
boast great power status for much longer
professor rana mitta writes in this
week's cover piece that china is facing
a baby bust its population growth has
dropped by 94 percent and it could soon
fall behind india as the world's most
populous nation what will this mean for
the future of chinese power rana joins
me now
rana mito welcome to spectator tv now
your cover article this week is all
about the baby busts that china is
imminently facing it's got only half a
million net births last year compared to
about eight million a decade ago i mean
all of this is deeply ironic for a
country that's so obsessed with
population that introduced the one child
policy so is that the policy is that the
reason that this is happening at the
moment or are there other reasons for
what we're seeing is such a drastic
demographic change
well cindy you're right to say that this
is a story that in some senses has been
with us for a while but really its
importance has only suddenly come upon
us and one of the reasons for that is
that essentially there's a series both
of short-term and long-term things that
have made china one of the countries of
one of the most serious demographic
crises in the world in terms of the
number of young people being uh being
born and growing up is becoming much
much smaller in number and the number of
older people who have to be supported by
the younger generation is growing larger
the one child policy mentioned is
probably the single most important
reason that this demographic decline is
so steep and just a reminder that
basically it was the late 1970s that the
government introduced a policy that
essentially forced the vast majority of
the chinese population to have only one
uh child uh there were some exceptions
in the rural areas for certain ethnic
minorities but overall it was one child
and that was it boy or girl didn't
matter and as a result
china's turned into a society which
historically is almost unique in there's
a whole generation two generations of
people without brothers without sisters
and therefore by extension without
uncles and aunts so that is very unusual
and of course that has led in large part
to the realization in the 2010s but
actually the the the success of the
policy in quote marks the fact that
population has shrunk by so much has now
led to a very different problem which is
the baby bust that's on the spectators
cover this week but there are a couple
of other factors that are more um
comparable to other societies and they
weigh in as well
but i'd say the quickest way to
understand that is to look at the
neighbors in east asia the neighbours of
china that's taiwan that's japan that's
south korea those other countries have
also been undergoing a really severe
demographic decline japan by some counts
might be in the first country if you
extrapolate an absolute straight line to
have no citizens at all in certainly 100
years time although i think it won't
happen in a literal sense but the
difference is those countries
essentially got to that much lower
demographics through a more natural
means they never had one child policy
it's just that they got rich during the
1970s and 80s became amongst the most
prosperous societies on earth and result
their populations became middle class
became relatively satisfied with their
consumer lifestyles and decided well one
child is enough or in some cases even
fewer you know uh just not to have any
children at all and in some ways as i
also say in the article the china of
today at least in its middle class has
got to a stage where a lot of people
actually think that one child maybe is
enough and even if the state wants you
to have more the individual living in
perhaps a crowded apartment with a job
and a lifestyle pursue doesn't want more
than one yeah absolutely and i see that
in my peers in china as well who like me
grew up from i mean i then had a brother
later in life but uh but for much of my
childhood i was the only child and to me
that was the normal thing see then you
grow up not thinking you want a big
family um so i think that you're right
to point out that normalization of
expectations part of what's contributing
to this um i want to pick you up on this
growing rich before you grow old uh
phenomenon that you're talking about
because in your piece you point out uh
that a per capita income of china is
twelve thousand five hundred dollars um
whereas to the same in japan is thirty
nine thousand dollars so you know a
third of the japanese per capita income
and for me as a chinese person with
family in china that's concerning to me
is is china's economy going to slow
essentially is it ever going to be the
biggest economy in the world if this
happens
well it's one of the things about the
tyranny of numbers you might say uh
cindy because it depends which direction
you're looking if you look west if
you're sitting in beijing or nanjing i
think you're a nanjing native i remember
correctly uh where if you look west far
west from where you are to india the
only other country in the world that's
got a single uh population in a single
country that's in some ways comparable
to china and according to united nations
figures may well next year 2023 become
the most populous country in the world
in other words that'll make china number
two population in the world for the
first time since the han dynasty which
of course as you know is more than two
and a half thousand uh about two and a
half thousand years ago um actually
slightly less 2 200 years ago let's uh
let's say for the heart of it but
just having to make sure i can pick
myself up up there about 220 bce to
about 220 ce but let's stick to the
present day with india now india is a
country that has per capita a gdp of
less than half
of china's and for a lot of people in
india let's say it's three or four
thousand uh us dollars a year they look
at china and say my goodness how are
these people managing to make twelve
thousand us dollars uh twelve thousand
dollars per capita per year they see
china's the great example to follow but
china of course isn't comparing itself
with india even though the population
size is very similar they're looking at
the rich neighbors japan and south korea
so there's a certain case of aspiration
envy that's going on here as uh as well
but the difference i think is this
in the case of china you have to look
and this is what one of the things the
article talks about at the demographic
shifts in the decades to come and let's
just hone in on one area because it's an
area actually many of our uk listeners
and actually probably international
listeners too may pay attention to
that's pensions now we all know that
around the world people getting a decent
pension has become more and more
difficult for a whole variety of
reasons spectators finance pages have
been very good about talking about it in
the last few few years but in the case
of china there's a particular set of
issues which is that as there are fewer
and fewer working age people and of
course those working age people are
still part of that one child generation
because it only ended about seven years
ago that policy so the people who are
growing under the permission for two and
three children are still only children
uh children themselves they're not
having to support much larger extended
families parents grandparents and so
forth then would be the case for their
peers either in india or in japan and
south korea and that's one of the things
that's very distinctively problematic
from the point of view of
of china there are some instant fixes i
mean if they could bear to do it which
is to say raise the pension age from 50
to 55 for women 60 for men but in doing
that they might also find that they have
you know even in authoritarian china
people on the streets protesting that
their pension rights which were hard
owned are basically being snatched away
from them to an older age so even for
the chinese communist party with all its
power raising the pension age would not
be a simple thing to do
and rana as you point out um in your
piece china's geopolitical power has so
often been predicated on its population
heft ever since the han dynasty really
and in today's world we can see the
people's liberation army you know that
stat that's often bandied around about
being the largest army in the world
does it have military and geopolitical
implications as well for china's
population to be shrinking
there are definitely military and
geopolitical implications to this uh
baby bust the demographic crunch that
we're seeing in china i mean as i'm
speaking to you in fact today um cindy
the day we're recording this uh nancy
pelosi the speaker of the u.s house
representatives has just in fact left uh
taiwan having visited there for a couple
of days on a village visit that's got
china very angry and the the angry
reaction has come in in part
from live firing of missiles into
the sea just off the coast of taiwan
carefully missing the coast but only by
a little a little bit and there's a
question about how far this military
approach is sustainable over time as
china's population gets smaller now i
think it's fair to say that china's
leaders have been thinking about this in
advance because actually one of the
things that's been happening really over
the last decade is that china's total
size of troops uh troop size has been
reducing it was over two million people
at one time which definitely
counted as the largest armed forces
anywhere in the world and that has been
reducing but still to you know pretty
large seven-figure numbers but what
we've seen instead is the other thing
that china is pushing towards which is a
much smarter type of technology that can
be used for military purposes so you
might think about a future assault on
taiwan possibly not being a d-day style
invasion but a blockade with
state-of-the-art warships submarine
warfare or cyber warfare these sorts of
areas the problem with that which goes
back to demographics is that you still
need lots of smart younger people who
are really savvy in that technology
and one of the things that i think is
putting people off a bit not yet kind of
hugely noticeably but i think it might
change in future decades is the people
who they want to get often uh young
chinese who've done phds at
international
universities and bringing their
scientific knowledge back to uh to china
well a lot of these people thinking is
this a country where really i can make
myself a career and the combination of
the knowledge that future generations of
chinese workers the young are going to
have to bear the price of paying for
pensions for the old combined with the
increasing political crackdown on areas
like the technology sector it's become
quite well known that big companies like
alibaba for instance run by jack ma
found themselves in deep political
trouble
these questions are being asked by young
would-be entrepreneurs to say well
actually is this the place where i want
to make the next part of my career now
let's not get it wrong for quite a lot
of young chinese this is still going to
be a kind of new wonderland where
they're able to invest make a lot of
money and work on new technology but
there are more questions being asked by
at least some of china's younger people
about whether or not the society they're
signing up for getting older and perhaps
getting more inward looking is really
the future they see for themselves
and rana i can't let you get away
without asking you this one final
question which is about sitting ping and
the possibility of him renewing his
third term um the chinese economy is not
doing very well the government has
quietly dropped its 5.5 percent gdp
target um and the imf says that the
economy is more likely to grow only by
about three percent this year uh we
talked about the housing crisis uh
presidency surely has a difficult
time on his hands so is his position
secure
so i think we need to differentiate two
things in terms of is xi jinping going
to get a third term in office this
october at the party congress i think
the answer is almost certainly still yes
i'd be very very surprised if that
weren't the case but the link question
of is there a different direction
potentially possible for economic policy
in china which of course is at the heart
of what's going on i think that's much
more likely china's economy is not doing
well in a whole variety of areas we can
see the property sector is really under
pressure a lot of big companies going
bankrupt younger people as i say feeling
reluctant to go into the employment
market or worrying they won't get the
right kind of jobs after training
there's this phrase again that's in the
article that you know very well um cindy
which is uh
yeah
you graduate then you're unemployed and
these sorts of things might mean but he
has to choose a prime minister to
replace the current prime minister nico
chang who's more inclined towards an
open market economy entrepreneurship and
less towards really top-down political
control if that happens then xi jinping
will certainly still be the president
and general secretary but we might have
to see a china that is is pushed much
more into opening back up to the world
and realizing that simply cutting itself
off in terms of a wholly enclosed
economy is the kind of thing that might
have happened back in the days of
chairman mao but in the 21st century
it's simply not possible
fascinating rana mitter thank you so
much for joining spectators tv
and if you've been enjoying the
spectators content on china do check out
my podcast chinese whispers it's also on
spectator tv so you can watch it as well
as listen to it wherever you get your
podcast from
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer now the
ruble looks strong the russian stock
market looks like it's stabilized so our
western sanctions on the russian economy
actually working o matthews argues that
they are in this week's magazine citing
a new report from the yale management
school but i'm joined now by dr richard
connolly who says otherwise he's an
expert on the russian economy
richard connolly welcome to spectator tv
now the question of whether or not
sanctions on the russian economy have
been working is something that
economists and russian experts have been
grappling with since the start of the
invasion there's a new report out from
yale management school which owen
matthews writes about in this week's
magazine and it says actually despite
putin's hype despite his myths the
russian economy really is tanking
whether or not you look at the rubles or
whether you look at the stock market
what's your take on that report
my interpretation is slightly different
to that of owens i found the yale report
to be a rather
weak piece of work and i'm choosing my
words carefully there it's written by
some people who i didn't see as having
any previous background in analyzing
what is in russia a very specific type
of economy um it's also a study i think
where the authors very clearly stated
their commitment to advancing a very
obvious political agenda
rather than presenting um what i would
consider to be um something that's more
required which is a balanced
evidence-based assessment of what's
taking place in russia now if you just
look at the language of the report
there's lots of references to an economy
that's imploding calls for more
sanctions etc and there's a lot of
citation of some extremely biased um
sources now that's not to say that what
can some of what's contained in the
report um isn't isn't accurate some of
it is i mean they refer to the shrinking
of russian imports some of the problems
that russia will face in reorienting gas
exports from europe to asia all of these
are points that i'd agree with um but
there's a lot that isn't um and that
makes it quite difficult to take its
overall conclusions too seriously i
think they overstate the extent to which
the uh russian economy is is suffering
at the moment and in doing so overstate
the
um the likelihood of there being any
change in um the calculus in the kremlin
i can give some examples of of some of
the errors that i think found their way
into owen's work if you'd like
i'll just give two because um there are
many more but one is on this question of
gas which is in the news um at the
moment and one of the points made in the
report is that europe is much more
important to russia um than uh russia is
to europe on gas and they they present
this in volume terms they say look you
know russia's got uh has only one real
really big customer that's europe and
europe has a diverse range of other
suppliers that's true however the report
doesn't go into the question of the
price that russia provides gas and the
fact is russia provides gas at a lower
price than any of the other suppliers so
even though europe's now buying more gas
from america and from the middle east
it's doing so at a much higher price and
that if this stays like this over the
coming years
is likely to mean you're going to see a
big reduction in european industrial
competitiveness and that's a i think a
really serious glaring uh omission in
this report the second um glaring error
is they talk about uh the cost of
russian oil
um and they ref they they actually set a
site in support of their assertion that
russia is a high cost oil producer a
report
um that was paid for by saudi aramco
ahead of its ipo
from a few years ago now this was saudi
aramco trying to tell everybody look we
do have oil cheaper than anybody else so
look russia is very high this was an
extremely biased report if you speak to
any sane person in the oil industry
including i would imagine the saudis
they'll tell you that russian oil is
amongst the world's lowest cost in most
of its oil fields
and
so it's these two examples i think show
you that um
there's some pretty egregious sourcing
um in the report these are just two i
think glaring examples and there are
many more and there are examples of
cherry-picking of data that the authors
of the report themselves accuse others
of engaging in
so richard do you think that sanctions
are not working then
i think it's important to
not conflate
exerting an impact with causing a policy
change right so i think if we look at
russia today yes it is affected by
sanctions undoubtedly but not as much as
this report suggests i think in its zeal
to make the point and to cherry-pick
data um this report does so in a rather
unconvincing way but what the report
also doesn't do and a lot of commentary
that i see in the media doesn't do is
take into account the political economy
of how sanctions tend to play out in
authoritarian regimes and in
authoritarian regimes of which russia is
one and the governments are very adept
at making sure that even though the
overall economic pie might be shrinking
that they allocate large shares of that
shrinking pie to people who will support
them to the regime's closest supporters
so they reward those who are loyal to
their leadership you see juicy
construction contracts given to insiders
privileged monopolies given to produce
substitutes for sanctioned goods um all
of these things keep workers in work and
they keep
the pockets of elites lined and as a
result it tends to mean that the regimes
are actually quite durable despite the
fact that sanctions are uh
exerting an effect that's how
authoritarian systems work uh and sadly
that's why they don't tend to fall under
sanctions and we've seen this a lot of
times in the past south africa in the
70s and 80s
north korea and iran and yugoslavia more
recently and i'd say russia since 2014
and
in my assessment um now and in the
future
that's fascinating richard connelly
thank you so much for joining spectators
tv
and finally are we losing out on good
ideas from abroad rory sutherland writes
in his wikiman column this week that we
need fewer think tanks and more theft
tanks to explain he joins me now
rory welcome to spectator tv now tell us
what is a theft tank
it's very simple one of the things which
business does which it doesn't talk
about very much is
we steal an enormous number of ideas
in other words companies copy each other
all the time if they notice something
that's successful elsewhere without
making much fanfare about it they go and
steal it
and it occurred to me that national
governments in particular are
extraordinarily bad for this
so one feature for instance of the
american healthcare debate
was at no point at all did anybody say
let's have a look at canada because even
by the law of averages okay canadians
peyton they aren't dying in vast numbers
on the streets the canadians are
probably doing something right
i'm sure canadians will tell you what's
wrong with canadian healthcare but for
example in the price they pay for drugs
patently they've got something right
okay
but for some reason it's considered
unpatriotic kind of not invented here
to admit to the fact that we're just
stealing from elsewhere now in the uk we
have a lot of countries not only
european countries in fact australia new
zealand canada are pretty good test beds
for interesting ideas i happen to notice
i went to israel
and they had a law in israel which is
that any company any utility you ring
like the phone company the water company
the energy company you ring
by law if it doesn't answer your call
within 30 seconds it has to offer you
the option of demanding a call back and
the call the return call has to come
within two hours okay
now
that was in israel absolutely brilliant
idea we could steal that straight off
okay what a fantastic bit of legislation
in germany they're introducing
legislation that when you subscribe to a
newspaper say online like the spectator
it has to be as easy to cancel your
subscription as it is to instigate the
subscription in the first place to
prevent this business where nobody will
subscribe to anything because they're
frightened of getting trapped in a
direct debit that they can't kill
and the first thing i'd like to do is
instead of using dogma driven think
tanks and the very business that think
tank tends to be left-wing or right-wing
tends to be a massive constraint on its
ideas to begin with because ideology is
not a great way for generating
originality you know you start off with
a very narrow framework of how you think
the world works and all you're allowed
to do is be a you know we want we want
to tax people more we want to tax people
less rather than asking really
imaginative questions about how do we
tax people differently
and if you look at the genuinely the
whole history of human progress
much more of it happens through the
transmission and spread of ideas
than through the origination of ideas
and yet i don't think for example in the
united states they still really haven't
cottoned on to roundabouts or kettles
okay you know they speak the same
language as us but they're boiling water
on the stove and they have the
ridiculous four-way stop which is
provably vastly less effective than a
roundabout
and yet again that idea simply doesn't
translate very quickly and if you read
books by matt ridley there's a wonderful
book by a colleague of mine sam tatum
called
evolutionary ideas
most ideas aren't actually a flash of
inspiration they're the transference of
an insight from one place to somewhere
else
british food didn't get better because
we made fish and chips better okay it
got better because we stole loads of
food from everybody else
and so i think it's it's a really
important point it's a kind of theft is
a kind of creativity repurposing a good
idea in something closely related is
still a form of creativity but it's
actually much more common and much more
valuable than we realize
maybe it's not maybe it's because i'm
not very ideological rory but your idea
sounds really good to me i mean i love
the idea of picking all of these good
things that happen around the world
but why do you think that it doesn't
happen it does seem pretty obvious now
that you mention it
i don't know i um i think part of my
little theory is that we have
politicians who are the choice of the
next prime minister comes down to
someone who studied pp at lincoln
college oxford and someone who studied
ppe at merton college oxford
and i wonder if there's a very big
difference i think between
practicing on the basis of theory
and theorizing on the basis of practice
and i think most of these people now
come into politics with an ideological
framework
uh and they see
dominic cummings was always right about
this he said in reality people real
people voters are both much more
right-wing and much more left-wing than
politicians imagine
and the the false dichotomy of left
versus right on a whole load of debates
actually
focuses attention on where there is
disagreement or where you can actually
score points rather than on where you
can make progress now the great thing
about business of course is even if you
hate another guy if you think you can
make money together there's an absolute
incentive for you to collaborate and
cooperate that doesn't exist in politics
well rory i do think that uh politicians
are probably quite happy to work with
people they don't uh personally like if
you just look at penny mordant's
endorsement for less trust this week
but speaking of the tory leadership
contest do you see anyone in our
political classes whether they're
running for tory leader or in the
political classes in general as having
fresh ideas
i'm not entirely sure the person with
fresh ideas
should be the person leading the party
but
to to borrow dominic's phrase of weirdos
and misfits
i think there needs to be a i think sir
alfred sherman performed this function a
little bit with the thatcher government
uh you know sherman would come in and
say there would there be some huge
debate on
rail transportation and sherman would
simply say why don't you concrete over
the railways and run coaches on them
okay
and we do need bolder
managed experiments um
for example okay
one of the fundamental one of the
fundamental principles of conservative
policy now is that you don't tax people
on the first nine or ten thousand pounds
of their income
now
that was a lib dem idea in fact which
the cameron government seemed to have
sort of stolen from lib dem policy the
idea that rather than reducing the tax
rate i would i would take that further
and say you should tax people less in
the beginning of their life than you do
towards the end
okay so your tax allowance should be to
some extent dependent on how much you've
earned to date not treated as an annual
allowance
and
what one of the things i find
disappointing you know
okay it's easy i work in creative
advertising it's not a high-stakes field
in quite the same way and you can get
paid for being a bit of a bit of a whack
job right okay i have a cush but i am
disappointed by the
there's generally just a
seems to be a dearth of lateral and
oblique ideas
in politics
now okay let's take video conferencing
okay or what we're doing now i mean
you're in london i can tell from your
offices i'm in kent okay you know
two years ago this three years ago this
engagement would require me to board a
train and
travel across london it doesn't okay
now this is potentially quite an
important technology okay now
it might partly help solve the housing
crisis if people can live further from
where they work not everybody has to be
able to do that just some it might solve
the transport crisis because not
everybody's traveling at the same time
it might help solve the pensionless
crisis because people can work to some
degree later in life i think most people
retire because they want to stop
commuting not because they want to stop
work okay
it's a very interesting technology now
it doesn't sit with any given ministry
or discipline
okay you know the ministry of transport
should really have been giving everybody
free zoom access in 2017
because if you you know but it's called
the ministry of transport it's not
called the ministry of not getting
people to move about so much in finland
they have a ministry which i think is
called the ministry of transport and
connection and they do actually look at
broadband connections alongside road
building
now quite often in in free capitalist
markets progress comes from completely
oblique things i wrote earlier that the
biggest news in home insurance in 30
years was the invention of the oven chip
okay because suddenly this profusion of
claims from chip fat fires which
required your whole house to be
redecorated even if the house didn't
burn down that suddenly died off
and the insurance industry would have
been better off actually paying mccain
the money to promote oven ships than
attempting to reduce their their current
insurance premiums
and so i don't think government has much
either appetite for or capability for
digesting progress which happens in
oblique ways
you know i mean the very ideological
fixation on tax rates seems to be
fundamentally
mentally limiting it's important you
know i i you know i i accept you know i
accept the fact that broadly speaking
you should give people their own money
to spend to preserve incentives but
equally
if people would rather spend money on
health than they would on sunglasses and
the only way to spend more money on
health is to tax people more
you know we need to have a more
intelligent nuanced debate taxing people
to pay for what for example and so i i i
do think that the fact that everything
effectively gets reduced down to this
very narrow polarizing
kind of
principles which is pretty badly aligned
with what people care about in everyday
life i think that's a problem
that's it for this week
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content join
today and you'll pay just one pound a
week for unlimited online and app access
in your first year to subscribe go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer and don't forget to subscribe to
the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks again
for watching and do join us again next
week
[Music]
you